so you're a bank in the early 1900s and
you want to make more money your biggest
Money Maker has always been mortgages
people taking out loans to buy a house
but buying a home at that time even with
a mortgage was only reserved for the
upper class the homeownership was really
rare for 1900s you look at the history
of 1800 obviously there there's
narratives about or stories about
government giving away land for free in
the western territories of the United
States but really home ownership or
owning your own home was a privilege it
wasn't something for the Common Man and
even sell the mortgages back then were
pretty bad you had to make a 50 down
payment and the mortgage was only for
five years so if someone wanted to buy a
hundred thousand dollar house they would
have to pay fifty thousand dollars up
front make interest-only payments for
five years and by the end of those five
years they will have to pay that
remaining fifty thousand dollars all at
once at the end it was basically a
convoluted way to break the payment into
two while paying the bank interest so it
was still out of touch for the average
person so as a bank if you want to make
more money you have to make these
mortgages more accessible to the common
men think about it right now your
customer base is only a tiny sliver of
the population you're only getting
interest from the top one percent but if
we can somehow structure mortgages in a
way where say 50 of the population can
afford one you are going to be rolling
in an ungodly amount of Interest so you
can talk to the plan a plan to get the
public health on mortgages and it worked
look around today and most of the people
around you will be in debt to the banks
for the rest of their lives most people
who have a mortgage right now are never
going to own their homes they're never
going to pay back their mortgage no
they're gonna die still in debt and when
they do die they'll simply pass on their
debt to their kids and you want to know
the best part is that every single
person with a mortgage today isn't even
mad about it after all being in debt I
mean owning a home is the American dream
and this is how the banks pulled it off
thank you
[Music]
it's 1933 and America is in the Great
Depression and the government was
desperately trying to figure out a way
to lift up the economy enter President
Roosevelt's New Deal the New Deal was
supposed to boost the economy and
promote consumerism and part of the new
deal was the creation of a new agency
called the federal housing
Administration or FHA the fha's job was
to encourage more people to buy homes
why would the government want to
encourage people to buy more homes
because when you own stuff like a home
you tend to work harder you tend to be
more productive when you can't own stuff
like in communism you tend to not want
to work so to encourage home ownership
the FHA this new federal agency created
America's very first home loans that
were guaranteed by the governments me if
someone couldn't afford to continue
making their mortgage payments you as
the banker claimed that money back from
the governments it seemed like a genius
idea at the time Banks would give out
more mortgages so people would own more
homes but as Charlie Murder says show me
the incentive and I'll show you the
outcome FHA mortgage insurance changed
the game for banks since you didn't have
to worry about defaulting anymore you
could just freely dish out more loans to
White poor people and so the 7 10 and 15
year mortgages were born but these
mortgages were very different instead of
splitting the payment into two and
making interest payments over those five
years these new mortgages are a lot like
what we have today where people would
make a smaller down payment to start out
like 20 or something and from there
instead of having a big lump sum payment
at the end they would just have to make
monthly payments for the rest of the 15
years where every month you pay down
some of the principal and interest at
the same time in the old five-year
mortgage system for a ten thousand
dollar home at six percent interest you
will need a five thousand dollar down
payment and then you will pay 25 a month
in interest payments for five years and
then at the end of the five years you
will be slapped with that other five
thousand dollar payments but with this
new 10-year mortgage for the same home
at the same interest rates you would
only need to put two thousand dollars
down much more attainable and then you
would just pay 88 every month for the
next 10 years and at the end of the 10
years that's it you wouldn't be slept
with a giant payment at the end so all
the commoners would have to do is pay a
measly 88 every month for 10 years and
the house would be theirs again much
more manageable and for the peasants who
can't even afford 88 a month you had a
plan for them too the 15-year mortgage
which would drop their monthly payments
down to just 67 a month it was genius
suddenly it wasn't just the rich upper
class that could afford to take out
mortgages now the upper middle class
could do it too you just unlocked a
whole new segment of the population but
soon even that wasn't enough so good and
bad right allowed more people to buy a
home but at the same time as more demand
it was introduced because there's simply
more able people to buy homes you have
prices of home go up increasingly this
is Sam quack by the way part of the
quack Brothers they help everyday people
pay down their mortgages faster so with
home prices up for more people buying
now people couldn't even afford your
15-year mortgages anymore so suddenly
you found yourself back at square one so
obviously you only had one choice to
make introduce the 30-year mortgage
[Music]
the 30-year mortgage would change the
real estate industry forever with 30
years to pay back their loans for that
same 10 000 house at six percent
interest people would only have to pay
47 a month down from the 67 a month for
the 15-year mortgage and it was
irresistible to the masses but here's
the thing the devil is in the details
sure on the surface these small monthly
payments sounded like a good deal but if
you actually run the numbers a 30-year
mortgage is actually a horrible deal and
it all comes down to a fancy term called
amortization and don't worry this war
sounds complicated because they probably
want to intentionally confuse you but
all this means is that most of your
monthly payments goes towards paying off
interest in the early years of your
mortgage instead of actually paying down
the principal and this has some really
bad ramifications when it specifically
comes to 30-year mortgages the first 10
years of a a mortgage amortization vast
majority of what you're paying every
single month is actually going towards
interest 5 10 15 year old users are also
amortized but if you look at the
amortization schedule on on a 5 10 15
year mortgages they're not as that bad I
mean you're not paying a whole lot of
interest even from the get-go on a
10-year mortgage really the vast
majority of what you pay on your monthly
payment is going to be principal payment
there's very little interest the problem
with the 30-year mortgage is that now
you've allowed time to basically cook
the interest longer right it's
compounding interest that's actually
working against you as a homeowner so
with the 5 10 15 year amortization the
interest isn't that bad you're not
paying a whole lot even though the rate
might be five or six percent but if I
the same five or six percent rate on a
30 years looks a whole lot different
you're paying close to almost 90 or 100
percent tip which stands for total
interest percentage if you get a hundred
thousand dollar loan uh on a five or six
percent interest interest on a 30-year
mortgage you're gonna pay a hundred
thousand dollars of Interest so your
entire total payment is actually two
hundred thousand dollars in the span of
30 years without a guarantee that you're
actually going to pay it off so let's
say you have a 10-year mortgage versus a
30 your mortgages right let's say we
have an example of a hundred thousand
dollar five percent interest rate on a
ten years we were actually ending up
paying as a total interest percentage is
you're gonna end up paying 28
868 so what your tip looks like your tip
is about 28.8 on a hundred thousand
dollar principal balance but you take
that same exact interest rate okay you
take the exact same interest rate and
apply it to a 30-year emerge
amortization what you now have is a 93
256 dollars of Interest you're gonna pay
so almost 93.2 percent tip total
interest percentage it's it's not
necessarily the rate that is the enemy
it's the time that you allow for your
principal balance to compound over the
last you know in 30 years that's where
it becomes a problem and of course you
know yes you have a lower considerably
less of a payment but that that itself
is the problem is that people oftentimes
choose short-term games short term say
savings quote unquote that's what at
least what they're thinking and
sacrificing long-term gain which is
considered has a considerably higher
opportunity cost it was genius for most
Americans the only thing that they
really cared about was whether or not
they would be able to make the monthly
payments nobody cared that you would end
up paying almost double the price for a
house when you attack on the interest
nobody did the math they were all
two-story eyed with the fact that they
could own a house even though they were
just School teachers or hairdressers but
up to this point owning a house was
still a little bit of a nice to have now
that you had these 30-year mortgages you
needed to convince the masses that they
didn't just want to own a home they had
to own a home
[Music]
thank you
it is now possible to have the
individual styling every family wants in
its home and still have all the benefits
of mass production
home buyers May select any one of the
authentic architectural styles for the
next decade you did everything in your
power to push the appeal of owning a
home you needed every last American to
believe that their greatest achievement
their ultimate sign of success was
owning a home you made sure that owning
a home became as important as getting a
college degree that no one could claim
to be a success without owning their own
home no one could imagine starting a
family without taking out a mortgage and
settling down it was white picket fence
Mania and everyone fell for it every
time a sucker walked into a bank with
all that hope and optimism in their eyes
you knew they were about to make you
rich and I know what you're thinking but
Jake isn't this okay if people
eventually pay off their mortgages I
mean they wouldn't be able to afford a
home otherwise and that is true but
here's the thing 30-year mortgages were
never meant to be paid off
[Music]
thank you
see mortgages are like a casino sure
some people will eventually pay off
their mortgage and be debt free but the
majority of people will lose so The
House Always Wins so basically what ends
up happening is you know let's say you
know I just bought a house uh and I'm
living in it I'm I'm enjoying I love it
but let's say you know I have three kids
and I only have two bedroom in my house
well shoot I'm gonna need two more
bedrooms to be able to house all the
members of my family you choose to sell
your house you list it you know you sell
it congratulations and you end up moving
to a much bigger house and you end up
getting a much you know obviously you
have to get a new 30-year mortgage but
what ended up happening there is that in
the span of you living in that house
from year one through year seven if you
look at your 30-year amortization chart
really what you've done is you've made
pretty much hardly any contribution to
actually paying down your principal
balance of the mortgage to actually
build equity now obviously there's
Natural Market appreciation that happens
eight percent every year but that
doesn't always happen in a Time the way
right sometimes monkey crash and Market
you know it's all cyclical but if we
look just in your mortgage really the
first seven to ten years of a 30-year
mortgage vast majority of your monthly
payment is going towards interest in
fact really Mass vast majority of
interest you will pay in a 30-year
mortgage period is going to be paid most
of that is going to be paid up front in
the five to ten year mark So when you
choose to move out of your home get a
brand new mortgage really what you've
done is you've made no progress you've
not moved a whole lot in terms of
getting closer to paying off your
mortgage building your Equity by the
time you choose to sell and move to a
new house so guess what happens that
seven to ten year mark of which you
decided to move to a new house when you
start all over again to with another
30-year mortgage you're going back to
square one where the the next seven to
ten years is now going to be interest
payments lots of interest payments and
you you're not making a whole lot of
stride and most likely when you move to
a bigger home anyway you've just tapped
on more debt than ever before so this
vicious cycle that most Americans are in
right now because now we're more mobile
than ever you know long gone are those
days where you stick around to work for
a company for 30 40 50 years and they
pay you pension and you retire
comfortably that is no longer around
that that is long gone right so now
people are more mobile than ever they
move more frequently they're switching
jobs more frequently the average person
the average adult will have 11 job
changes in their career which is a lot
and the odds of you having to move or
relocate to another city or place is
rather High these days because of how
how vast these companies are now so with
that being said you can expect for most
U.S adults to have three four even five
mortgages for their personal residence
and each time they get a new mortgage
they're recycling resetting that 30-year
amortization clock so by the time they
get to their 60 year old 50 year old Ray
change they still have 30 years left to
go and so yeah you may have a three
percent four percent low quote unquote
historical mortgage rates but who cares
if you have to repeat that front loaded
interest Zone the first seven to ten
years over again literally five times
throughout your entire lifetime that is
where the Trap is and this is why I
encourage people to really pay attention
to this even though their interest rates
might be three four five percent okay so
basically this whole scheme system has
evolved into something where the average
American they basically become like
indentured servants to the banks where
like so much of their income for the the
rest of their entire life is strictly
just going to paying off interest and no
one even really realizes it and banks
have you know they pay I mean billions
of billions of dollars on perfecting the
system right I mean they can they
literally hire people who graduate from
MIT Harvard all these fancy schools that
are people are a lot smarter than us
they have actuaries that are like math
geniuses and what they do is they
compute the risk and reward of these
millions of homeowners getting mortgages
so what most people haven't really asked
themselves is how are the banks getting
away with such low interest rates and
yet there's the most profitable than
ever before in the history in the last
100 years I mean shouldn't they have it
more profitable when the interest rates
were of 12 13 14 15 right or you know
eight percent right I mean we're kind of
back to that spot now but if you think
really think about it the way that they
got to they're making way more money now
is they figured out they figured out
what I know and what I'm explaining to
you is oh most American homeowners are
moving five times their lifetime whereas
100 years ago it was only like once or
twice so let's go and build that into
the computation of risk and reward so
yeah we can give give them a three
percent interest rate but really if
they're getting five mortgages a
lifetime and most of what they're gonna
do is make interest payments yeah that's
oh that's almost like on paper it's
gonna be like a not it feels like a 9 or
10 interest rate as opposed to you know
three percent forever so this is how the
bigs you can't beat their math and the
way that they're able to make their
money and a lot of people who during
covet were like oh my gosh I got a 2.5
interest rate I I am like hardcore
winning right now I'm saving so much
money guess what I mean a little bit of
secret dude three or five years you're
probably gonna end up moving and
whatever the rate's gonna be in three to
five years that's what you're gonna end
up with so good luck with your two and a
half percent interest rate for the next
five years but really you're gonna end
up in the same spot or in a spot where
three to five years from now the
interest rates are going to be closer to
six or seven percent so again the rate
is not the game you should be playing
the rate is there it's it's a lever and
a mechanism to which the banks can use
as a marketing tool not necessarily a
way for you to save or make money so
don't play that game because that's what
the banks want you to play okay the
moment you play that game the moment you
follow the bank's rules you've lost
because banks have created that world
for their benefit and they're for their
profit mortgage payments make up 31 of
the average American household income 31
and you know what that means right
because they're going to be paying off
their mortgage for the rest of their
lives you have successfully duped the
public into spending a third of their
lives working for you a third of their
lives as your literal indentured
servants and when they die their kids
become your indentured servants so we
are not being hyperbolic when we call
this debt slavery and when you take a
step back and see all this you gotta
give the bank some credit this is a
genius system they've come up with it's
the best business model ever and we
haven't even talked about
mortgage-backed Securities yet which
we'll save for another video but let's
say you're aware of this trap and you
only get a mortgage once you know for
sure that you're not gonna move that
you're gonna keep this house until you
pay it off well not so fast because the
banks have one more trick of their
sleeves to get you as well
[Music]
the next way you trick plebs into being
your slice forever is what the magic of
refinancing let's say someone bought
their home at a seven percent interest
rate and a year later interest rates
went down to five percent they could
just refinance their mortgage and get
that five percent rates which will
magically lower their monthly payment by
a few hundred dollars a month neat right
that makes it really looking out for me
about offering this or so they thought
oh we're at six percent let's go to five
percent so that we can get more people
to go refinance because I'm gonna tell
you right now refinance business is more
profitable than people buy like first
time home buying business think of it as
like when you first get a customer
you've had to pay a lot of marketing
costs advertising costs to get that
customer right so a lot of times when
you first transact when you first have
an interaction with the customer you
either Break Even or you lose money but
the second time they come back to you
okay now that's profit right because you
have you have to spend money to acquire
that customer again so what banks do is
all right because we're losing money
anyways on these first-time homeowner
customers we're gonna offer a ton of
incentives we're gonna get them to buy
and get mortgages from us once we got
them six to seven years later let's go
ahead and advertise a refund funniest
raid so if Bob Joe got their mortgage at
six percent let's wait five years
collect some interest right and then
tell them hey we have a five percent
program so come back in get another
30-year mortgage for that five percent
you're saving a whole one percent and
they'll do all these kinds of
advertising of going oh Mr Bob Joe
you're paying 600 a month we can get you
down to 550 right and they're gonna try
to do all these types of advertisement
so refinancing is a very very profitable
uh business for uh mortgage brokers
Banks investment bankers because this is
the mechanism to create more
mortgage-based Securities it's literally
they have to feed the beast if Wall
Street is a beast and wall Street's
hungry for mortgage-based Securities
they need to make more mortgage-backed
Securities and the way how to do that is
get the Americans to take more loans out
that's it and literally the banks and
these companies will spend billions of
dollars on Advertising promo incentives
right like I've seen some stupid things
like hey get a mortgage today and get a
free cookware set right like what right
like and there's people who fall for it
and like oh my gosh it's like a German
steel cook set I need it right and they
get a refinanced freaking crazy so you
have to understand it's the interest
rate yeah that's what the more the Wall
Street makes but the banks also make
what's called an origination fee okay uh
also known as a loan doc fee or whatever
and these are also very very profitable
to these mortgage brokers because if
they can sell a 30-year conventional
Fannie Mae a fairy Mac backed FHA
mortgages if they can sell that they
could make two to three percent
commissions even as high as four percent
commissions off the loan loan balance so
if they sell you a hundred thousand
dollar FHA loan they get to go home with
a four thousand dollar commission check
so guess what their incentive is let's
get as many people as possible to get
these mortgages but it doesn't end there
remember how we transitioned from 10 and
15 year mortgages to 30 year ones
because home prices got inflated too
high well the same thing hasn't been
happening ever since
[Music]
what is the next logical step 40-year
mortgages of course which the FHA is
already testing out and don't worry when
the day arrives and the masses can't
even afford a 40-year mortgage we'll
just roll out a 50-year one alright so
enough of pretending to be a bank how do
you beat the banks in other words if you
don't own a home right now should you
should you rent and if you should buy
should you get a mortgage or not and if
you have a mortgage what can you do to
get out from under the scheme let's go
over that next
[Music]
so first one we'll cover you know what
you recommend for a person just starting
out they don't have a mortgage yet so if
someone's just starting out like they're
in their 20s maybe they're starting to
make some money like what do you
recommend do you get a mortgage do you
just rent for the rest of your life yeah
so I mean the most important thing to do
is really understand how the system
works right the moment you understand
how the system works and how the game is
played and what the rules are of the
game you can quickly figure out how to
win okay most Americans unfortunately
and I'm not just talking about mortgages
I'm talking about money and how to make
money and growing your wealth in general
most people don't know how to play the
game or they're playing the game that's
been set up for them and they don't have
any other they don't know what what
other ways to play it right most people
are like oh work 40 years put some money
in the 401K stocks bonds oh yeah and
then put some money in crypto or
whatever right unfortunately that's game
plan for most American homeowners and
people in general but yet they fail to
understand that there's all their
Alternatives right there are other
investment vehicles through real estate
through insurance parents through
alternate investment opportunities
there's so many things you can do you
know starting your own business there
are ways to play the game of wealth
differently and oftentimes they're way
more lucrative and the growth potential
is way higher than just playing the
normal average game same is true when it
comes to paying off your mortgage if you
understand that there's an alternative
way of financing and buying homes you
can actually beat the system by paying
it off early so one of the things that
you know I teach and this is something I
teach to my clients is a cash flow
strategy whereby we're going to show you
how to pay off your mortgage in as early
as five to seven years without paying
any extra into the existing mortgage
we're not going to play that game
without refinancing to a lower rate
because we talked about how stupid and
dumb that is We're Not Gonna Hurt our
credit or modify or beg the bank beg the
bank for Mercy we're not going to do any
of that it's all simply by careful
allocation of where you put where you
store your money that's it in an event
where you put your money in your income
your savings in a savings or check
checking account the banks win because
they can take that money in your
checking account use that as a
collateral borrow more money from the
Federal Reserve or other Banks and lend
more money out with an informal mortgage
of course and make more money off your
money right you're literally giving your
bank a free loan right if you have any
money sitting in your checking account
at I'm earning zero percent yourself the
bank is taking your money and making a
lot of money with it so instead of doing
it that way what I teach is use other
vehicles such as lines of credit or you
can use other vehicles related to that
to take advantage of what the banks
offer to then ultimately save money on
interest and also pay off your mortgage
faster so that you don't become
susceptible to the traps that I talked
about uh being perpetually stuck in this
30-year death trap that's something
that's something I teach so know the
system understand the rules understand
why the game is playing being played the
way the way it is because it's all in
favor of the banks yes buy a home but do
it smart and use alternative strategies
that you know stuff that we teach to be
able to help you now there's also the
philosophy of should you buy or should
you red I think I believe if you are
going to stick around your next home for
at least 10 years you know for a fact
you're committed for the next 10 years
and you're willing to make that
commitment then yes buy if you feel like
okay I'm gonna do some a lot of hopping
going from one area to another area to
another area probably not the smartest
thing to buy just yet figure out what
you want in a home and where you want to
be and then make that decision so just
really understand be educated commit and
know thyself of where you want to be and
that's the biggest thing I would have in
terms of recommendations for people just
getting started out so there it is
unless you know for sure that you're
gonna live somewhere for at least 10
years do not get a mortgage and if you
do get a mortgage or if you have one
already there are ways to pay it down
faster so that you can get out of this
trap as soon as possible and if you want
to learn more about Sam quack's white of
paying down your mortgage faster in as
early as five to seven years scroll down
and click the link below to learn more
about it now scroll down and click the
link below to learn more now the quack
Brothers of the paid sponsor of this
video and of course I am not a
registered Financial advisor so you
should definitely check with your
professional Financial tax and legal
advisors before making any financial
decisions this video is for information
purposes only stay dangerous and I'll
see you in the next one
foreign
[Music]